صباح الورد والانوار والسرور على صباح
العربيه وعلى كل مشاهدي صباح العربيه
سمعنا الهادي جويني وهو يغني تحت الياسمين
في الليل والعظيم ايضا محمد عبد الوهاب
يقول يا ورد مين يشتريك نحن اليوم في قصه
من الشارع 40 عاما من شراء وبيع الورد
وخاصه بيع الورد محمد ولا ايش قصه حب
عظيمه للورد وقصه تضحيه ايضا واسرار على
التمسك بمهنته رغم كل الظروف التي استجددت
في هذه المهنه رغم كل المساعده التيته
يشهدها اهل الانقطاع محمد بيتا حقيقه
واجهه من الواجهات السياحيه لمدينته منزل
بوزلفه ولي تونس عامه باعتبار انه يرافق
الفنانين والنجوم والمشاهير والمنتخب ايضا
التونسي في سفاراته وهو منذ 40 عام يجدد
قصه حب مع الوارد كل يوم سي محمد مرحبا بك
مباشره معنا على صباح العربيه
محمد التمسك بهذه المهنه ما هو الدافع
الذي يجعلك تتمسك بهذه المهنه وتتنقل الاف
الكيلومترات من اجل مهنتك الجمهور الشعب
جمهوري خلاني جمهوري اللي يخليني نمشي له
بالذمه انتقل له حتى 300 كيلو متر و400
كيلو متر لقلعه بيت تحب له لعبه تحب تصور
معي وغرامي 40 سنه وفي دمي منوار
الولد معندنا مرتاح
من الغرام اللي يخليني كنا ناخذ طياره
400 كيلو
بيع الورد تونس
تتدهور السياحه في تونس قرر ان يخرج من
محافظته نحو محافظات اخرى ابعد لكي لا
تموت هذه المهنه هذا الاصرار سي محمد على
الا تموت هذه المهنه هل تعتبر ان هذه
المهنه مهدده ام انها مهنه سوف تعيش مده
زمن
موجود الورد بيتنا وكده اما معه تلقى شباب
قول يا بابا من الجمل ماذا بينا نحبه كيفك
كيف الاكل من الجمول انا الغرام اللي
خلاني اوصل للكيكه وبس نحب بلادي ونوري
على بلادي وفك وتصوريها في العالم كله في
العالم
الجديده لممارسه هذه المهنه التي تعتبر ان
هذا ممكن من الاسباب التي يمكن ان تهددها
تفرجوا فيهم
يا عمو
محليكوا معايا المشكله
حريف التونسي او زبون التونسي او خلينا
نقول المغارب ايضا الذي يتواجد دائما في
تونس على غرار الجزائريين الليبيين
المغاربه الى ذلك هل كان هذا الحل ناجعا
في تونس وكذا معناتها وقف الخدمه شويه ما
عاد سياحه
من الحب للخنتي ومن الغنم تاعي موقفتش
نقلت نعم ماشي احد داخليه سياحه داخليه
ولا بالورد ولا بالياسمين
[موسيقى]
جميع المناطق اشتغل فيها محمد الذي الذي
يصير دائما على ارتداء زي التقليدي
التونسي مثل ما نراه الان امامنا هذا الزي
الذي طاف العالم الحجاب التونسيه الفرمله
وكل الزيئه التونسي نعم احلام ما اعرف اذا
انت شايفتيني انه على راسه كثير
معي على الفستان الورد اللي على راس احمد
بس شكلها طيب احلام العبدلي نشكرها جزيل
الشكر على محمد من تونس في امان الله